i love
crafting
a great movie theater experience just
like thinking of all the elements in
advance to make sure that like yup this
is going to be great because when it's
great it's great like i go
early in the day
don't i don't go at night i go unless i
absolutely have to i like to go early in
the day
i like to go to the alamo or someplace
where you can get a meal at the theater
like i'll go right like like the last
movie i went to was uh batman and it was
perfect it was a movie great i heard it
was too long oh did you i've heard that
i mean
i've heard one of two things stupid
people think three-hour movies are too
long no but if if someone doesn't like a
movie and they feel like it's three
hours then it feels too it's not better
than dark knight though is it or it's
close it's not better than dark knight i
do better than dark knight dark knight
was [ __ ] dude incredible dark knight
felt like a good movie where the main
characters happen to be superheroes if
that makes sense it's just it was dude
the opening scene with the bank robbery
yeah and then ledger dude i mean i saw
it on imax too oh i would have done a
couple of dialogue things different but
it was just comic bookish
what kind of dialogue things just a
couple of lines i would have written
differently i didn't then i was like but
i still love them i love them in that if
you're written batman i'm not wearing
hockey pants like that
was there's a couple of lines you can
remember that that like new york cop put
on like bad ears yeah he was just
sitting there fat he's like what's the
difference between me and you he's like
i'm not wearing hockey pants
i'm like yeah yeah yeah a couple of
those yeah but like those christopher
nolan batman movies are also like really
big like he does big
very well and like this is a much
smaller
movie which i think is the way it should
be like if you can't cause people [ __ ]
up when they like if it's too big
it's bad but like i think christopher
nolan just does
big movies really really well yeah
like inception that was a huge i loved
inception i thought it was crappy
one yeah but i i would have to see it
again i i don't remember it but i
remember
like it's so long ago that i gotta see
it again yeah you gotta that's one of
those that you have to watch the whole
movie and you have to pay attention to
it like you can't be on your phone you
can't like yeah you just like you really
have to pay attention to the details i
would watch that again though i remember
liking it when it was on um and not
being a hundred percent sure exactly i
should watch it again yeah lots of
theories on that one yeah yeah good
movie but it's all there
yeah like you know what i mean like
there's enough in the movie to unpack
it's not like
it just fell apart yeah
it's good though but yeah dicaprio is
dude dicaprio i mean i just watched
gilbert grape again the other night like
part that just was on i was like i
forgot how great he was as as uh arnie i
thought i honestly thought willful wall
street dude his performance in wolf of
wall street certain scenes were just so
great man so great he's [ __ ] he's the
i don't think he's done has he done
anything
bad like where he did a bad job no he
was great in this boy's life gilbert
great basketball diaries titanic was a
very good like you know it's like it's
not that it was
still he was well acted he was fine yeah
he did uh
departed he was awesome yeah
i thought you know it was great and
departed time in hollywood who doesn't
get enough credit well they give a lot
of credit to like uh marky mark and leo
dicaprio i thought alec baldwin matt
damon was tremendous yeah yeah because i
feel like matt damon is generally a
pretty likable guy and he was such a
piece of [ __ ] yeah like you know what i
mean by the time you get to it he just
is such a piece of [ __ ] that i'm like
yeah that's that whole movie was just oh
i love it you can catch me granny he's
incredible gangster new york was great
um what else did i think you know there
was something else he was really good
into oh uh the aviator oh he's a great
navy howard hughes right yeah yeah
i don't remember i never saw the man in
the iron mask i don't know what that's
about it's a little early ah yeah yeah i
don't need to
that's it he just crushes it man he's
great gabriel's awesome yeah he's
gabrielle is awesome especially when
scorsese gets involved i love when
scorsese finds a guy yeah and he's like
this is my guy like the first half of
his career was de niro like that's my
guy and literally everything scorsese
and de niro did was incredible yeah and
then the second half he's like nope
dicaprio's my guy now and then
everything dicaprio and scorsese do is
incredible oh dude shutter island i like
was that shutter island was good shutter
island was really good i liked it at the
end
[ __ ]
i might have seen it but don't remember
it some people don't like it some people
thought it was a hokey but i thought it
was really good i enjoyed it a lot they
had deleted scenes for titanic
oh jenga by the way the fact that oh it
was great in january yes the dialogue
yeah you like it as a book yeah yeah
yeah
i i just got excited about the titanic
scenes delete i just i don't know why
they did the one with the season there's
more
[Laughter]
but it was just like a long like love
story it was it wasn't like i'm not
re-watching titanic
again it was another one i kind of
re-watched recently i did cry a little
which i don't know i know i know i'm
watching titanic and crying like what
are you doing you should be disgusting
and and and and and it's like the whole
it was on so i watched it that's not a
thing anymore everything is available at
your fingertips literally everything you
can't beat
this the um
the visual of jim norton alone in his
home uh crying to titanic is one it
would be one of the greatest things i i
i will say this uh it wasn't i'll tell
you no it wasn't that part that didn't
make me cry it was i forgot that at the
end they showed them all alive
uh when they i was like oh it's nice
yeah but i was i wasn't alone
i wasn't alone when i watched it i was
with a woman and uh the word she used
was very appropriate because she's not a
crier no it's not fruit a much harsher
version
she used that to describe you oh yeah
yeah she did i mean what are you doing
watching titanic with a lady in 2020 i
hated this part the old bag threw that
thing off when she drops the thing
her veiny feet each i was the worst
[ __ ] old [ __ ] throws that thing
while i hated her guts for that no i
didn't cry at that
this is the part right here
yeah i had forgotten about this it was a
nice ending oh yeah it was a nice ending
but i forgot about that all of our all
of our favorites just this part i
thought was it was an interesting break
of the fourth wall which i kind of liked
see we it's all the people that we loved
at the beginning of the boat voyage yes
now they're at the end but i hated the
old lady oh wait so they all they're all
dead all these people oh yeah they sunk
in the boat there's a bunch of frozen
corpses i barely remember this part this
is titanic i had forgotten about this
part this is okay yes it was nice can
you imagine dying and going to heaven
and you're stuck i went on one boat trip
i'm stuck in this [ __ ] boat in heaven
and you're the guy in the corner you
have to watch this guy [ __ ] a six
[Laughter]
but she's not dead what the hell is she
doing there that's a great point yeah
she's not dead i guess she's doing it i
guess it's just the old lady's dream
yeah maybe oh i didn't even catch that i
think it's the old lady's dream
it can't be titanic heaven or hopefully
the thing she was thinking of as she
grabbed her chest and fell back don't
[ __ ] throw that expensive jewelry in
the ocean yeah [ __ ]
yeah
exactly generational wealth one guy
[ __ ] you once he sketched you [ __ ]
you in a car and then drowned and you'll
throw away two hundred thousand dollars
you told the grand cause grandma threw
out your [ __ ] yeah yeah that was like
watching edgar winter throw away a
[ __ ] small fortune
[Laughter]
do you think she died there in the end
and maybe she went to titanic i hope so
no i think no i think she lived yeah
this business had a dream
she's old she's gonna die at some point
she threw the jewelry out that's the
last thing she had to do she told her
story i think she died but that's just
the fact that she threw it out i just it
made me hate her guts even more than i
did it's like holding it is is would be
mean more yes and giving it to people
and selling her i hate her toenails
being painted too
who pedicured that lady
yeah no i think she died here
i think she threw at the thing
because she knew like okay i'm done
and then she went to bed and died and
went to titanic heaven except for some
reason everybody in titanic they died
they're the age when they died and she
gets to go back in time because she
lived for 80 years after the boat sank
and it's never been as good as when
leonardo dicaprio [ __ ] her in the car
in the boat oh like don't come near me
oh she shows up that he should [ __ ]
to get it back if i watched her drop
that for some a moment of emotionalism i
would you know i would do i would
[ __ ] i would i would plant a good
kick into her spine
a sidekick i would wonder boy kick her
in the spine
oh i forgot she did it in front of all
these people yeah you know what that's
worse oh alternative alternate ending oh
okay that's why i didn't remember that
oh alternative she gives a big speech
what's the speech
i'm dealing with logic here i know that
but please
think about this for a second they all
have dollar signs in their eyes about
this for years
and i've come all the way here to put it
back where it belongs you piece of [ __ ]
you have grandkids you [ __ ] just let
me hold it in my hand
please
this guy's a weirdo huh yeah but he
knows how to get this from the old i'll
give it back to you then you [ __ ]
throw an elbow into her jaw just put a
[ __ ] shot in her neck and put her to
bed
okay he's holding it now he should
snatch it and run because yeah exactly
shove her
i hate his face right now he's just
coming in his pants because he got to
hold the titanic necklace in the wrong
place
only life is priceless oh shut up
you killed leonardo dicaprio because you
couldn't share your floating doors i'm
so happy they cut this and they just
like oh this sucks boy if he doesn't
snatch this from her crib keeper hands
he deserves to be broke
he's just snagging from her and start
running and she'll pull it out of his
hands he's on the [ __ ] seven train
oh
he's gonna release it but the music it's
not a victory
it's not a victory
well he's realized that life is more
important oh jesus oh jesus
and then he got it and they got eaten by
the propellers
[Laughter]
just chopped to death a shark just
[ __ ] feasted on him yeah would it be
great from the from the water you just
heard up on the boat hunt
good honestly titanic is a terrible
movie this part sucks
his look
and if she has if she has grandkids yeah
she's a selfish old piece of [ __ ] that
means that like
she moved on after the boat she married
somebody she had kids with that person
that person or her kids had kids with
another person and still all that
matters to her is the dumb boat trip
this laugh moment i'm happy where he
realizes she's right
i know i hate i hate them
pointing at the factory look how fat you
are that's all it's about she'll break
his finger in half and then i'll hug you
they get it can't swim fatty
million dollars in the ocean that's a
good point she had a whole other life
and that [ __ ] necklace could help
could help her the people that she
actually lived with she's a disgrace
because she threw the necklace in the
water and then she she dies in her sleep
and goes to titanic heaven instead of
the spending heaven with the people that
she actually lived her life with yeah
exactly you [ __ ] uh you [ __ ] a broke
guy on a boat and then you and then your
whole life has been built around getting
back to this yeah you were slapped
you slumbed it for a weekend see there
if there was an italian if my dad was on
that boat they're getting scuba diving
that [ __ ] back
i hate that ending i that was terrible
even more
when he gets it that made me not like
the regular movie more yeah yeah yeah
yeah no she's a garbage person the lady
for sure yeah she sucks and she's
selfish she's a selfish old bag i mean
think about it you
people have been on trips before yeah
where it's like you were on a trip for a
weekend
you met somebody you hooked up with them
oh that was great now i gotta go home
i'm gonna miss it was it a weekend
there's a day he [ __ ] her once
no i mean [ __ ] you're on the boat but
you know what it was a big boat accident
grandma where's that shiny diamond
necklace with the blue heart i threw it
in the ocean
i remember the guy that [ __ ] me in
1912.
he [ __ ] me in 1912 and i threw three
million dollars into the ocean
oh dude that's brutal yeah that movie
kind of that movie kind of overall was
just like yeah it was it was like one of
those entertaining but not great in the
theater there was one part i cried at
but that's in the theater are you you're
a cro are you a crier for other movies
uh yes unsub what part did you cry in
the theater the old people in the the
water was filling up the old people who
were hugging each other yeah i remember
that that was kind of sad forrest gump
got me forrest gump that it was a couple
like i didn't i didn't you didn't burst
out crying but you just you got that
like that dude crying
yeah oh yeah yeah what part was it uh
there was a couple man yeah there was a
couple the when he was raising his son
alone and he was just like you know when
his son ran to the bus and he just goes
hey and he just looks at him he goes i
love you and he goes i'll be here when
you get back and like the mother was
gone already and stuff like that and i
was just like because he was just hated
he was a simple guy but he was
yeah yeah there were a couple there was
actually a couple parts when his mother
died and she's like it's part of life
and stuff there was just it was just a
cup it was a that was a tough movie man
yeah i hated her speaking in in in in
poetic prose to that [ __ ] dunce
really drove me nuts yeah of course you
got her life is lacking shut up yeah
and did she tell you what life life's
teacher yeah life is like whatever
teacher i [ __ ] that's going to get you
into class exactly nice metal shoes dick
it's like it's like could you just ask
first and like
could you have asked them first like
before just by the way jenny gump didn't
deserve any of force affection didn't
deserve that child she's a [ __ ] he's a
garbage yeah oh you should come yeah
come on i love you now that i have aids
yeah yeah like i did literally
everything like [ __ ] guys balconies
and [ __ ] taking jizz all over the
country with a [ __ ] music career yeah
when she shows up with the hiv and a
short hairdo
hey i got the plague give me a kiss yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she just she's talking about
showing up when it's convenient for you
who's gonna take care of me yeah oh the
simple guy yeah from back home i love
that he buried like a german shepherd
under a tree
yeah i mean
yeah i didn't care about when he asked
if forrest was stupid when he asked if
his son was stupid i think that was the
part that got me when he was trying to
ask if the kid was stupid you cried a
little there too but when i saw it yeah
you see him 30 years ago
just
just the idea that like
he was he was down
he was down for her from when she was a
kid yeah she was a child getting abused
and he had her back he's the [ __ ]
ride or die that stupid saying that it's
always like she's my ride or die she's
my right ginny [ __ ] yeah just took
full advantage and you know forrest
probably uh because he wasn't bright he
probably had a very [ __ ] hard dick
and he probably just pounded away when
he wants to be [ __ ]
durrrr
he probably [ __ ] her properly i mean
there's nothing right here dude waitress
there's nothing in the movie that would
tell you that didn't happen no it didn't
hey get me a coffee aidsy
okay
ah oh [ __ ]
get was it chocolate city
stunk man she was a bad person bad
person yep she was horrible
yeah always a drug party he's always
leaving him getting on a bus yeah oh i
kept the scrapbook of you here's your
brother running yeah and then wasn't she
in some like cult or she was in some sex
cult i'm sure yeah i'm sure she was
nexus nexus that's so yeah she's brand
new and then and then he beat the [ __ ]
out of the guy that hit you
right didn't he beat the [ __ ] out of the
guy yes he did [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of the guy that he
he's protecting you and then you still
left and you still got on the bus i'm
starting to think these hoes ain't loyal
i mean from jenny gump to the old lady
in the titanic these are horrendous
humans you know what karma karma and
that's why she got sick that's right he
has a kid she's gotta tell her that's
how that works she hasn't selling for
five years i heard you got apple stock
she's here for her money she shouldn't
have had anything
she knew about it she heard about the
apple stock says she's like right now
i'm gonna [ __ ] see you for back child
support yeah let me let me let me end my
life comfortably with your apple stock
yeah
yeah it was good i mean it was a good
movie though honestly i mean there's a
lot in the movie philadelphia is a very
good movie has nothing to do with
forrest gump except the aids thing i'm
the same actor but the same actor
doesn't have aids in both that's a great
one
what'd you guys think of castaway
i like uh yeah when he's on the island
yeah i thought there wasn't enough fedex
mentions
you mean it was good you mean castaway a
fedex story it was it was hard to do
it's the same thing about him made that
good is what made i am legend will
smith's performance good it's hard to do
something by yourself for that long
that's why the island and the island
stuff i think is the best stuff in that
movie i liked i am legend better than
castro i did too yeah i thought
it was great and that when i still think
that every time i drive up that thing on
park avenue i think of that scene when
he goes and that [ __ ] statue is there
yeah totally that was so cool when he
went into that dark room and they were
just sitting there like breathing and he
had to be quiet because they were just
like that that was like i thought it was
very good yeah i haven't seen it in a
long time but i remember like seeing it
in theaters and everything it was good i
saw it in a theater my wife and i and
another couple and my wife went over she
goes this is [ __ ] great i was like
the helicopter reveal at the end as the
story is told about his family it's
great yeah oh that when like the with
the pup when the dog was a puppy yeah
when you see the family leaving on the
helicopter did you realize what happened
it was very good yeah i uh i heard that
they're making a sequel yeah they're at
least working i was legend
or i am average
[Laughter]
uh tommy in north carolina what's up
tommy
hey man i was just gonna say you know
and you know
uh how she didn't have him just set up
as a patsy how do you even know that was
really his kid it almost definitely was
not his kid it was because the kid
looked like him he put his head to the
side he didn't look like him it was
haley joel osmond that kid looks nothing
like tom hanks yeah but he worked she
could have definitely been on a coke
bender that's somebody else's kid it's
not his kid yeah i mean he had sex with
her one time it's not his kids
i named him forrest after his daddy
yeah and he thought it was a clan guy
stupid [ __ ]
thank you tommy yeah
that's a good point dude she's like it's
probably parties and all these sex
things yeah she's having sex all the
time
she got eights yeah you know i mean yeah
i don't think it's his kid
i love that call it's so funny how do
you even know good point she's out
gallivant i don't know